happy Monday everybody I welcome back
Brian thanks buddy I want to Florida
counts to a couple Florida couple
Californians have a little Florida
Panthers well Florida [ __ ] I want to
start this by saying that Miami is well
I'm you know I'm a Cuban man right I'm a
Cuban man like in my blood like I went
and got tested the way I'd the way I
moved the reason merengue and South's
that comes too easily
the reason the way I make love I tell
you I guess you were salsa dancing the
other week and a friend of my attention
went hey you should know a few things
that was sewing minds a terrible dancer
that was so funny and I just take salsa
hustle like what the [ __ ]
yet I bleed or not I wasn't there to
dance I was there to pick up my buddy
Amir who was dance I day at all I know I
know he goes come meet me we were I
wanted to grab a drink with him he's at
this salsa think Sofitel hotel and I'm
like what the [ __ ] I said hey come down
so I'm like alright well you know we're
not Street a little stiff they told me I
wasn't there I literally somebody yeah
video girl I don't even know and I
started dancing with her it was so
awkward for a couple minutes just and
then I left I know I was like goddamn
yeah I'm not a Miami sure did seven the
morning not seven the morning I do power
96 and they are it is a disco I walk in
doodoo it's that Latin [ __ ] and I start
dancing without even thinking about it
next to her on meringue going with with
the co-host sure just to she's amazing
no no no hey Matt's a woman that Oh
curves for days that's Miami Miami is
curves for date you got Columbia flat
ass what do you do this I'll tell you
move oh I'm glad you asked you move no
I'm glad you move to Iowa I got a
solution what I gotta hold that thought
you got Columbian you got Venezuelan you
got Colombian well Cuban Puerto Rican
it's such a beautiful Latino people
Hispanic people have a secret I think it
comes from like my soul Justin who
manages the [ __ ] out of the Miami improv
the [ __ ] my new favorite club what I
he do the best he grew up in Little
Havana
his mother was Dominican I think his
father's Cuban something maybe the
opposite his father was coming anyway it
doesn't matter when when when you grew
up in Little Havana
your grandmother's cooking basically a
variation of plantains rice and check
it's the ambiance black besides
everybody comes in to that house your
house is always full 27 cousins are in
the backyard plant you grow up like that
psychologically it's the best thing you
could ever do because you're around so
many different people it's all I love so
I my my my feeling is that I've never
seen a group of people more
psychologically ground they're just
[ __ ] happy when I when I got my pick
up thank you very much school got picked
up how about to find out online instead
of from you you [ __ ] dick I know I'm
session D I got to find out from Julia
you're dead to me but but they came out
with a cake they're like whoa the whole
staff I was just like only [ __ ] in
Miami yeah now now I'm glad you asked
about the ass thing now I'm naive as you
know flat ass get out of Miami yeah or
or if you have an ugly face get out of
LA or if you have both your fate your
[ __ ] is harder to fix although they can
fix now your fire your ass which I
didn't realize you fight a is that your
I know now your ass your ass if you have
now all they gotta do is it's that
s-curve operation as you know where they
dump a little they take fat from your
ways o Lord your objects with long
shooter in your ass now my our boy
Stevie blue eyes his girl he's in this
sick condo his I walk in this girl is in
a compression suit so you told me I
could talk about this so it's all good
and she was already had a booty she
already died me done yeah already a dime
piece poetry but she decided to get a
little more a little more often in the
trunk so she got the job done now hold
on because she got a Brazilian butt lift
and this where people confused okay so
it's not implants no exciting takes fat
from your body your midsection maybe a
little you know that fat tricep you know
talking about yeah yeah the little fat
yeah a little [ __ ] frog neck yeah
yeah yeah our key gobbler yeah take all
that and go cool story
I'm gonna fix and make everything flat
when it dump into that ass that's right
Hatter yeah in the back how to gain 20
pounds how to gain 20 pounds you say
like a mother from you whatever you want
but then they so look that the lady have
[ __ ] the best they perfectly round it
it's unbelievable
I've had some experience with it oh yeah
I've had some occasion for test drive
and you have I prove 100% you do approve
a thousand pretty
it's a real-ass which I again again it's
I mean snow yeah I'm in Miami looking at
these crazy asses and Stevie is gone
well that's been done Brian that's been
done of them because some of them are
people think my girls s fake yeah that's
real that's every other mama
no no that's real yeah 100% some people
think at all that's fake they're not
some some women and by the way most
Latin women are pretty they're working
with you if you if you have a flat ass
as a Hispanic or Latin girl that's like
having a small dick is a black guy
that's why I love this operation you'd
you're so [ __ ]
yep but that's why I'm so happy with it
by the way all this six-week you know
what they do so it's six weeks you're
not sitting down for six weeks
his girls on her so worth it his girls
on her tummy they're also so worth it
don't worth it it's so as a massage they
massage the fat into your body oh dude
I'm telling you for my dozen her mass I
would pay for it 100 you so an so can't
think if you rent had a tiny dick maybe
does you don't care if I'm gonna assume
some things there so let's say you did
have a small dick yeah and you could pay
for an operation where they just inject
it with fat and this thing goes it's
just you like how much six grand
[ __ ] yeah hundred piss and lay on his
back for the next six weeks every guy we
know what being debt every guy and every
go through the protocol to yeah it was a
hundred grand we ever got be in debt I'm
telling you college you'd have your
college payments in your dick pick your
if you're a girl there's no reason
should have flat ass now
there's no excuses [ __ ] tits out the
front it's five dollars based on your
lips dude you set even if you're [ __ ]
ugly ten G's right now twenty G's in
your fine geez get you everything you
need titties in the front check spot
lights in the front
check donker out the back check check
and this is new dsls check you know no
reason to be ugly now let me ask you out
the dsls do they put do they put fat in
there because I don't like that college
a gel they put collagen I got a problem
girls it doesn't take yeah dad that's a
problem I can always see it's fake and
that makes it hard I know a girl who she
and it looks so painful because they
stick sharp needles all in she did it
four times but her body or my dad was so
high their body would just eat it up
then you have to get implants and [ __ ]
it's bad I spell I would imagine it
depends on the doctor so look at that
girl from left
before to look at the right I like her
period she's got a good mouth what do
mean uh chin you mad that she doesn't
have a goatee no this thing right here
needle in with the eagle eye ya leil or
is it a herp you never know yeah you
don't know dude and you know what poor
girls so they go through all this and
then you've seen the eyebrows [ __ ] they
do know oh I watched a friend of mine
get her eyebrows done what yeah they
they basically sketch it like they take
like you know like the the prongs from a
[ __ ] like a like you're a Polynesian
get a tattoo they do that they scrape
your eyebrows black so they're basically
like cholo style where you don't have to
do mascara with Aiko they put a
permanent
yeah it's called micro bleeding oh wait
they put a permanent eyebrow yeah yes
you do it like every few years all right
so so in other words goddamn plastic
surgery is astonishing this is there's
nothing nothing
we got [ __ ] nothing I gotta be old we
could you can tweak it you and ask me
what you said I got an ass but I'm not
having an ass I'd be ridiculous also
violence we need to work on Brian's
eyelids so we can even remember that
yeah girls get the the scraping of the
eye so they never have to do their
eyebrows for makeup anymore so they get
that so I don't understand so that zero
that's him that's astonishing I'm
soaking your teeth done veneers you got
no reason if you have means to money to
be ugly these this young kid yeah
contacts in your eyes in Miami after my
show this young kid handsome kid about
6-3 he goes I got my black belt and
chickenheads alright well you're the
best looking young man I've ever seen
that makes sense yeah and he goes I'm in
dentistry school and he like in front of
everybody goes this is my pledge to you
when you and sha want veneers I will I
will put them in for you what I will fly
down there and do it I was like come on
man you gotta have some more experience
here he's a little young I gotta wait
till he gets really good yeah i'ma have
to see some people you've work done dude
I'm but my thing is that with technology
you can give someone a real ass make it
permanent so they have that tiny waist
in that ass that every other ways well
yummy so you gotta be a
you're dieter that fat just goes right
back well yeah but they but something
stays that way for I love you he like
[ __ ]
yeah you can't be a pig but but at the
same some girls I've seen some girls of
smash in Miami
I saw one black girl with this dumper
this [ __ ] dump truck in the back I'll
call it a dumper though cause I think of
poo you show great for no dudes another
word dude she has this dump truck out
the back but she you could tell she was
born like a girl like my like a ass like
my girls yeah but then was like you know
I'm not big enough
oh no that guys around here want it
Baker so she got the implant it was like
can't have implants no I mean I'm
playing she got the fat stuffed on top
of already an ass
it was so distracting beYOU got worse in
black white Latino like beauty like you
everybody would be attracted to that oh
you know except it came is that for chin
no even even shrubs like this guy in the
world would be into like if you're if
you're the Grand Wizard of the KKK
you're gonna let those girls you let
them yeah you end up the end that
becomes your side piece that you can't
get rid of
yeah it's true cat would you ever who's
been over this said you do titties I
don't think I would do titties anymore
but I did look into what you're talking
about we can like fat from other places
[ __ ] in I saw this girl at the gym
with the most like amazing but and I was
like wait how did but she doesn't look
like she really works out so I asked her
and she told me that she got oh great
yeah she's be really thick she got all
the fat just put into her hips and her
butt Wow amazing good she looks so good
then you want to do that you think I was
researching it up well I started go
funding for that project cat so some
photos of my feet yeah if we were like a
week at would you do that would you
would you begin cata we could go we're
getting cat a dump truck and people
would give you money look at that but
right there in that no the pink right
there is that a drawing or is that real
wish calm that's that's impossible
that's an impossible rump you said you
do it though cat yeah probably
I'm like pretty on board if it was paid
for what's your man say about it oh he's
like go for it you didn't care he
doesn't care
plus better to look at that's not true
listen man I mean who wouldn't if it's
six grand
who the [ __ ] wouldn't be pretty painful
I can't live like that
so if guys like making take some Jesus
guys if you can take some from my
stomach and put it into my calves or my
chest or my I need a chest I loved
average yeah we can't take some of
someone's fat dump into Brian's bird I
don't want a fat chest no no no we
shouldn't put some muscle yeah well we
can't do much in pillow fat and I want
you lera fat what are they gonna grow
most I guess I take steroids but my my
chest would still be you know what I
mean it just wouldn't I know any
injected bro I need I need a yeah I want
chin would you ever do anything you want
some chest implants no I don't think I'd
do anything would you pay for your guy
to do yeah look at that he got there
what happened there is they have a bin
plan oh my [ __ ] off what is that though
what did i do looks real natural - what
do you mean if you went from [ __ ] tits
the left to the [ __ ] all right you
got implants yeah dude
well you get about it pick you know
that's all I got your hilarious it
that's so weird to be so funny you can
barely tell though yes doesn't seem
worth the money yeah dude not like an
ass he get his biceps done look at that
yeah but I saw I saw a guy with bicep
implant that stuff's creepy you're the
biceps already strange how about the app
implants like these they look terrible
you look like a ninja turtle it doesn't
make sense
oh my god they get in the bottom at prom
that makes sense it's strange one dude I
think so what are you gonna do with that
stuff what can you do I'll do it stop
don't give yourself 10 implant your jaw
and let's go this Jim man and eat more
you think look or just don't have a
chest like me you want fruit for girls
though it's different man I'm all for it
I am all for it well when it's real I
mean when you you think those are a real
ass feels all right congrats on man your
choices there dude
when it's real why not
damn they hooked him up
somewhere your [ __ ] goes on the world I
mean I prefer fake titties in real -
well what's gonna happen you do yeah
really yeah what's gonna happen I don't
so what's gonna happen is I'm a hater
ultimately they're gonna be able to gene
edit and stem cell [ __ ] so you're gonna
have women with tits they're gonna grow
tits and that's around the corner sir
yeah but then everyone's around
everyone's gonna look the same and so
then the fat ugly girls you be the in
thing then and then the big out-of-shape
dudes can be in well beauty does like
that's my move man Judi changes right so
the Victorian era was in too soft it
kind of heavy women cuz it meant you are
healthy like beauty in certain cultures
usual things curves have always been in
style always guys are it's in our DNA to
like girls with fat asses and bacon I
would agree but there you go that's what
beauty was back then you can't really
tell them cuz they have so much [ __ ] on
we have no idea yeah she looks like [ __ ]
have you seen the African tribe where
the women have giant asses where they
store fat have you seen that sir in East
Africa why'd you bring up talking about
Atlanta
no no I'm talking about there's an
African there is an African tribe that
has where women what do you like them
jin-tae camera the name of the chin
tucked in East African women yeah but
they're beautiful like so Ethiopian
women Eritrean women Somali women are
[ __ ] gorgeous by the way so it Kenyan
women they're also earth so we're a lot
of that they really are like the Masai
like you see some beautiful beautiful
I've been there we don't we don't know
the tribe name I don't know that let's
move on before change it's a virus it's
all good dude lifetime to get to it they
can be like worry where they just have
fun I think they hold they store fat
have you heard that group of white
people that were in Denver let's have
huge dicks in the front yeah he's had a
tribe needs a family called the shop
dude your brother from a [ __ ] trunk
is a trunk
I was so Shambo baby right in power I
think right without yeah yeah
saw that thing and I was like I I did a
double-take out what I sweat and whoa
and I tried to chase him I go where you
go thank you escapes he doesn't let me
look at I'll let me get let me take it -
did you I gotta take it in hey hey go to
Tom Seguros Twitter Tommy what Galgo
Jesus Christ Cole is my girl and Tiger
goes icon poison you're here no question
know the koi sound is the South African
tribe that that's yeah but there you go
look at that yeah that's my wrongs of
them oh well it's not fake hey Ching go
to Thompson girls Twitter he posted this
guided he's got a new beat and he just
it's all nude beach he's like summers
coming and this guy's walking the nude
beach and has the biggest dick just
flapping around and they see some guy in
the background just a small dick and
watching him is that true yeah I keep
going what if it got flagged it was
yesterday yesterday yeah what do you
think he said something like summers
coming and it was [ __ ] hilarious
no did he get flagged oh there is can't
get there just can't wait for summer fun
it's blocked it looks like yeah oh your
media setting look first draw the beat
repeat this guy who is there no a little
big that's it that is that's crazy
congratulation on lap it around it
looked like it was half hard look like
half a chub so I don't know there's a
wake yeah just flat I mean that guy's
not a great big chest look at how skinny
his legs are got the skinniest legs ever
found something on him his dick is so
fat lying around that [ __ ] that big a
standing kind of straight up and I feel
oh that's no law and you know that in
San Francisco you can walk around naked
but you cannot walk around with a
hard-on do
are you and I are therefore live find
the kid years ago and the guy had a [ __ ]
ring uh or do I went and his body looked
like warm cheese he was every bit of 65
he look like an out-of-shape armadillo
with this boyfriend what a nice a go
great outfit guys oh you hit a [ __ ] ring
ugh yeah that guy's got half a boner I
don't think so I think it's just fat I
gotta walks by my kids I'm getting my
back foot ready and I might I'm I gotta
get ready first of all I'm gonna call
child services if your kids at a nude
beach with men ever tell you there was a
place called fire and ice I think in New
York City where my girlfriend at the
time that I was dating sort of this
stripper and she was all hot she took me
down there and it was kind of a swinger
club and Alston I look around there are
dudes jerking off look when these guys
are sitting there's one girl getting
whipped and another girl goes this guy
was would you spit in my face please man
my girlfriend saw my oh Jesus Christ
so long story short there's a dude with
a giant dong african-american fella very
muscular with his white sweats down
around his mid thigh and he's just shank
and shiny shankha and I do not rolling a
dude behind us cuz this girl's getting
spanked and he's watching and a dude is
sitting down and the circle goes you
[ __ ] hit me with that you hit me with
that bro I'm gonna punch you in the face
hit him with it like hit bus or not
because you hit me with that I'm gonna
and then the guy goes up [ __ ] to
stand in there man relax that I didn't
do [ __ ] yeah and the guy who's jacking
off with a beat the [ __ ] out everybody
in the room he was huge and this guy's
like yeah well just [ __ ] it a guy warned
you he goes don't [ __ ] threaten me
with and they're having an argument
while he's struggling deaths
oh [ __ ] that's most alpha male move ever
what's up bro with a dick and by the way
it was so big it curved to the right you
could [ __ ] around a corner it's weird
that you talk [ __ ] like I would have
been like wall jacket I would say
anything yet get out of the way no I
just wouldn't say anything well this
kind of work to do that was a nice
holiday that was my size and way too
aggressive and would have gotten stomped
by this essentially we got myself a
linebacker
we got choked that was cooked yeah well
I mean his dick that was fat
every bit the size of my [ __ ] I
remember just marveling at it you know
mate were you jacking off
I'm a stayer absolutely not definitely I
was jacking off just one around like
Where's Waldo was I no no not only that
but I met she knew somebody I shook his
hand and then I saw him jerking off
later and I looked at her I go I want to
have sex with this girl so I go let's
get out of here and go have sex which we
did I got the [ __ ] out well if she's
into that yes with morning sex yeah
she's like oh these are my friends she
got stopped off and dropped some
electrolytes off to the boys you
definitely [ __ ] her yeah and then she
kept telling me that she was having
orgasm after orgasm but I didn't believe
her well I was doing that I was like you
know it did be and also this is not an
accomplishment I'm just having sex with
you don't tell me that I'm any different
you know I mean like what I'm just
moving you know you don't don't flatter
me busting nuts bro yeah and the black
guy was with us obviously and he brought
me my idea and then you yeah yes
did you watch Game of Thrones last night
I sure did thoughts well I mean you know
come on it's pretty epic that here's a
like it here's the thing and I'll be
spoiling anything because I've been
getting texts about people I mean ATMs
like what the photo shop now Tom - Tom
shops had suck my day so so um I don't
want to get your take on this so amazing
episode I had no idea a dragon could do
that kind of damage he bull for sure and
two structures oh yeah I mean one night
when he said you got three full-grown
dragons it means everything dies but to
see what that thing could do but I was
amazed that she she she proved that
she's not a leader
Daenerys oh I know she proved that she's
ultimately not the rule but she's always
kind of been a villain she's think about
she's a villain like remember when her
brother got [ __ ] remember would with
when he got when it had melted yeah
remember that and she was like that's
fine like she was cool with it well and
she's done certain [ __ ] we like it's
kind of dark
yeah look what eyes think there was that
possibly dark right she's evil like she
she's a villain and then on you when you
do that to all those innocent people
when you didn't have to it's like
something changed with you you got
isolated and you she's gone lost she
went really you went with her father the
man yeah yeah so she's just like in her
and yeah and our father burning
everybody
and so it was all like you know it all
stems from that her she's following the
footsteps of her Pappy and then a great
accident she's great great job and then
she doesn't like she just doesn't have
any love from anyone so then it's like
like [ __ ] so what you went John snow
pulled back like to say I'm she's like
alright cool bro revenge it is owe me
night I'm gonna set everybody on fire
now dude you know my only critique of
the show and you know I don't like to
take master paula's what is it a story
thing or is it a visual thing story hand
visual I want more did you want to see
Cersei have a different demise yes I
wanted a dragon to I want I went up
close and personal like putting her on
[ __ ] she's been such a [ __ ] such a
[ __ ] raging [ __ ] yeah then going to
black while the [ __ ] villain father I
didn't do it enough for me now I like
the Romeo and Julia ending how they died
together I mean that was cool I like the
way she I did see her she was just
terrified for her she died like a coward
in the end and he not really like just
the building fella like I felt like this
is not her there's some yeah he loved
her there's been some [ __ ] that went
down I felt like I loved that character
I got me Jaime Lannister so Duncan I
would get white Daenerys damn flat like
the dragon is flying around she's just
chilling the castle roll up then just
blow her up yeah like I'd like to see
her set on fire she blew everything up
around her so she could watch everything
she had just go but she doesn't have the
satisfaction Leonard watching her die
more like I'm gonna remember that that
was built that was base belong her
family but here's the other thing is
Daenerys and Circe's never cared about
the people she always hate the people so
yeah she she knew that like she was down
to let the people die yeah so it didn't
make sense
I was like no make her suffer man
there's some badass murders in that
episode but that one I was a [ __ ] I
thought they held at least they went out
together I [ __ ] out that [ __ ]
dragon is so scary indicating you to
death oh my god what does she say to it
when she went when I killed
what's-her-name Dryad
drake indra Narus he's dragon drogon or
some [ __ ] but what does she saw drug on
he's all
ya know it's something it's a different
thing she says something Jakari took
courage
dakari sounds right to a car I saw that
mean that's like you're up do you
remember when that when the dragon was
small and they got I was trying to hold
on to it yeah he said they don't take
orders from people other cars [ __ ] dude
you cannot [ __ ] with a dragon well if
you have that huge arrow and they're not
ready for it you can already for that's
about it now is such a good episode
people are hating on I don't get it they
were yep you know everybody wants to
hate on everything that's how it goes
that dragon is no joke do can you
believe it's the season finale next week
it's the end but there's three spin-offs
that all prequels what wait three
spin-offs we Google that [ __ ] think
they're filming in the summer yeah
dude you're doing prequels but dude
that's I'd like a little more sizzle
from Jon Snow during that episode like
he's just like what yeah well you know I
also thought about as an actress so the
Hound had an amazing arc that was the
bad these are great by fire yeah they're
great actor the Hound in the in the
mountain I was amazed I was the best
scene in the whole yeah it was amazing
great actors but the but you know if you
look at Cersei if you look at her her
job was for the most part for the whole
season except for that last scene was
just her staring with intensity and
saying one thing yeah you have one word
yeah but that that's that's what acting
the big moment was the shame shame you
know she'd walk like that was like kind
of the most we really saw guys season do
you see the mistake they made they put
Jamie Lannister when he's hugging her at
the end before they died yeah they have
his real hand back there no they don't
they [ __ ] up again seriously yeah yeah
yes these people pick up on things I
don't see this it's not interesting yeah
look [ __ ] does that happen I don't know
how it happens because you you have to
shoot you do pickups you're shooting so
many things you don't have the money you
lose location right there circled yeah
where is he right there touching her
back how to [ __ ] two people pick up on
this [ __ ] that's a big deal man in the
detail this size of a [ __ ] I can't see I
can't tell though there really you know
no but if you're a fan of the [ __ ] looks
good
that's his really him well it doesn't
look like the fake hand cuz the fake
hand is gold yeah you're not a real fan
I found this scene very touching no the
most touch it not me
the most touching scene I found was the
between the the Jamie Lannister in the
the [ __ ] the door when remember when
he when he when he came to rescue me
that you gotta go tell sir she's like we
gonna take the boat he's like you've
always been great scene you've always
taken care of me yeah you knew you were
the only one sir that's I yelled misty
during those [ __ ] [ __ ] dude and then he
starts crying hugs them cuz you know
it's the last time they probably can see
each other okay yeah I'll have a good
time together
what a great show men what a great time
what a historical time for them season
finale next week bro is it the actual
whole series is done oh that's whatever
that's why it's a big deal it is like I
don't wanna doing second a meal I know I
think it's so decided do not I forget
I'm like all Game of Thrones I woke up
at 4:00 a.m. on [ __ ] Sunday morning
in Tampa Bay like [ __ ] I you know for me
it's like I gotta I gotta watch the
fights tonight I legally bought from
who's buying lately
what come on man would you uh I thought
what Rose namajunas couldn't have looked
better and then she yes she's got a net
crowd I hate seeing him I hate seeing
someone lose that way I mean you may
have a different take on it but I mean I
felt like Rose was so much better and
now classing nothing taken away from
what's her name Oh Josh yeah but um she
just looks so incredible better than
she's ever looked completely winning
running a clinic on her and then she got
thrown on her head which is fighting but
what she knew throat she didn't spike on
her head no she just got knocked out I
just hate seeing that
I'd rather she not what makes it so you
said what makes for great though yeah
you said a long time ago that rose was
just a phenomenal athlete oh yeah
way back when yeah she's a little beast
yeah as good as it gets
I'll be if if if Kelvin verse style
Benner did 70,000 I would imagine this
does around 20 or 30,000 buys that is
the strangest thing I could sell you
[ __ ] in a cup for $19.99 to get
30,000 buys yep yep maybe I'm we're
gonna do that I'm gonna come dude how
about much for being a [ __ ] in a copy
how about on Howard Stern they in it's
an old one buzzer since that's really
specific yes I don't know why I said
that and some of the old Howard Stern's
they went back to it was beers and
something they went to like a gay like
parade or something they're talking
these gay guys like what they're into
dude I had to turn it I was like eating
like a salad or some [ __ ] my truck it
was so disgusting you know I listened
some [ __ ] yeah I was like I'm gonna
change it because I'm gonna throw up
yeah eating this [ __ ] quinoa salad
yeah the time how they pissed each
other's the ass I know it's one guy
surprised how many loads have you
swallowed - he's like eight it's like
thanks guys guys are extreme I think
well it's just dudes man
like it wasn't like you know it wasn't
like your typical like spot on gay guy
who's like well hey he's ok how's it
going oh yeah and he's like so what he
been doing ayzik you know I did some
piss [ __ ] and is [ __ ] yeah really
pee in their ass piss [ __ ] piss and then
I had to turn off he's like so uh like
what do you been doing ayzik I've
swallowed eight loads bro like okay no
it's okay I have I don't know I I mean I
don't know I do know why I'm doing the
loads but I mean I yeah but that's what
for me it because so few I'm super
strengths can't imagine swamp invite I
felt sick I can feel my [ __ ] yeah
there's a lot of us again I don't finish
my lines no yeah there's a lot of that
weird like but thing where I want to do
things yeah even know that were they pee
in there but but they can pee in come as
my mother would always say I don't know
man as my mother would say anything you
have thought of has been done doing
person and he unfortunately and sexually
there's all kinds of weird what do you
guys do this weekend Teddy K oh wait
hold on what on that note I know that
what's going on I I got ruined a long
time ago when I saw Robert Mapplethorpe
a controversial exhibition Robert
Mapplethorpe was a photographer a very
very talented amazing one who died of
AIDS but he he did some gay erotica now
you might want to bring up you might
want to bring up one of his images just
just type Robert Mapplethorpe images
controversial images and I want to just
see if you can I've never heard of them
no he was so he was a huge it was he was
a huge thing okay and the reason he was
huge is because the the National
national donors had to pay for this but
just keep going I want you to see well
there's that that's always good right
there but keep going please
that's it keep going they were all good
there there you go stop there for a
second I wanted to just take that dick
in for a sec that's cool bit of a route
okay and as a hoodie keep going that's a
good picture there you go let's let me
just see that that's him who's that
that's him with a bullwhip in his ass
that's him with a poet but it's not oh
that's no big deal keep going thicker
part yeah really art where I come from
we know he's got a tail food that's him
alright all good get there yeah Wow
fully loaded yeah call that one loaded
fully loaded keep going yeah I just
wanted there he is again
that's Iggy Pop they're different
different actresses he died of AIDS yes
he'd no way look at her with a giant
dick on her look at that the [ __ ] nurse
yeah keep going though there's one night
I went there you go beautiful cats
Salvador Dali I'll go to all the images
well I want I want there's one that
you're pretty that's Sally that's not
that's Sally that's not him that's okay
Sally yeah let's just look at all the
image so we don't come across something
crazy oh look it's gonna that I think we
got the idea though big oh that top
level you don't know no no it's always
good but this thing I got it dude oh
wait go to the gonna the one over
which one is some of this stuff here all
the way to they know there you go let me
see if that's nope okay getting so
there's one where there's I just have to
have bread and see it though you have so
you haven't if we could just keep
scrolling down for just a quick second
do you know what you're looking for you
yeah I do I know exactly what I'm what's
the posture the posture is just a penis
and it'll be involved and a fingers
involved Oh in the dick shoot yeah he's
got his finger shoved in the guy's dick
well we just type that in fingering I
want Brennan Jean if you wanna hire son
you can I want to ruin his Monday I want
to ruin his Monday that's all yeah there
you go
there you go mmm controversial yeah well
anyway that was part of the break just
get away huh
even on the Internet yeah something even
then I kiss you know what when I saw
that I went I went too much I believe in
that or not got you there's some [ __ ] on
the internet they went you know what
look this is where we draw the line oh
there it is there you go that looks like
there you go that that must feel good
whatever you do that that hurts me
looking at it I gotta pee I do too now I
do too now so there there you go that
would be that would be what the National
Endowment of the Arts was paying for so
do you think it's a little controversial
if you were like my tax dollars hold on
like it was a huge huge issue on
censorship and what it means and then
and then Scalia Justice Scalia the
Supreme Court you know he just
they were talking about how do you
define pornography and he famously said
you know what he said no he famously
said I don't know how to describe it
you know we fight but I know when I say
you go and there's like how do you
define obscenity I don't know how to I
said I know that oh yeah what'd you do
this weekend besides look at pictures
like this I went to smorgasbord on
Sunday what's up it's this like almost
like a hipster food festival like flea
market notes no food stands it's in the
Arts District
what was he good yeah it's good a lot of
different options it sounds fun I like
going to places where I can try a little
bit of everything I don't want one big
meal for this bird a bunch
little more smarter be yeah well you
know you know a few trick at my crib
this weekend you're coming right
under em this Sunday Sunday so after
that for okay I'll be back from Orlando
me to check me out more than a Friday
Saturday I'll be at the improv
wait um I'm coming from New York
straight to there Ju be there okay
perfectly I'm definitely gonna be there
so what is the equate occasion like my
specials on Friday Wow
so I can't watch his people on Friday so
we're just doing we're not watching my
special just having like a cell yeah
great we'll have a celebration and then
can we do it Game of Thrones are you
gonna need you leave by 6:00
you need everybody out of there yeah so
fly me to the party only two hours six
yeah that's eight I'm especially an hour
long yeah but I get food truck there but
that's a little rude I mean what if I
gotta get you out so that no lingering
no linger who throws a party from 4:00
to 6:00 this guy I gotta watch American
out up five game of thrones at 6:00 but
what if I'm a lingerer we'll see go in
go in another room
you seem like a talker not during Game
of Thrones not for the finale you should
have it should bleed in finale party
100% not I people leave no I don't like
those people enough to have them yeah
but everybody there I know they're all
my friends a family I like him enough to
watch Game of Thrones ease with this I
gotta watch fights with anybody here you
actually you should have everybody there
for Game of Thrones 100% Tata be there
yeah we're watching it I don't think
Todd must watch it I'm not I was like
hey what time's your party I'm like sick
yours perfect how you at home I'm not
leaving will you dress up like Daenerys
yes yeah okay I'll be a dragon I'll
dress up as drow ride you yeah you put
your finger my dick hole oh yes you
[ __ ] dragon piss blood tell me Kat um
hi my I just found out that my sister
and my cousin are coming to town
so it depends on what they want to do
you don't wanna come to our party
heaven forbid you should get two hours
to yourself you don't want to come to it
to our party where you get kicked at it
six [ __ ] does that get priorities dude
oh my god Game of Thrones that is
crashing you're coming I was gonna go
for sure if Cal is going but then I was
like God you of course I'll be there
what food truck do we do cat prints of
Venice Oh chin if you show up with your
boyfriend I'll be so excited to bring
someone you probably don't chat or Steve
or John in your apartment and you don't
bring that brings whoever you just
brings a guy who's super pale who's been
traumatized who lives in a box you
talking about a [ __ ] yeah this is my
friend this is my gym I mean his name is
chat Gary his name is Gary like
something's up with this man he's not
saying anything the guys over there and
the ass chin if he could have a piece of
cake his chin said no yeah she would I
would do I don't have cake uh I judge in
hitting him super hard I should get a
cake in the corner um Jim what do you do
this weekend though it was Mother's Day
weekend so [ __ ] forget Mother's yeah
why didn't forget I take my mom did you
do anything my buddy I did I spent time
with my mother my children and my mother
though dad seemed I got yep I got to
because what happened was I miss my
flight on JetBlue because I couldn't
bring up the bar code even though I'd
already checked in and I missed the call
and I was like and they're super helpful
in Fort Lauderdale to super health
indictment hey guys can you just print
out my now it's closed I'm like I got 30
minutes make my flight sorry if it's not
there just bring up my boarding pass
sorry I can't do it you can go to the
help desk nobody they push you off I
miss my flight cuz I was there 37
minutes early how mean were you you're
37 so [ __ ] early is it though but
it's early I closed the gates a third I
was checked in already
no they closed the gates at ten minutes
before I was I was I was furious feeling
bored thoroughly and bought myself a
ticket I had to go through image by
another thing through Cincinnati yeah it
cost me on Delta I bought it right there
at the counter that's fun that's cheap
and then got on the plane and and got
home at 5:00 saw me who instead of one
dicey dicey it made me crazy but yeah I
Mother's Day always annoying because
well you don't need a single day you
have to do something it's like
Valentine's Day just try not doing
something let me do it on my own time
you know hurt people's feelings
yeah
it's all good though did you do anything
for your mom yet yeah I sent her flowers
and then I facetimed with her for a bit
while she was eating dim sum okay she's
in northern Cali mm-hmm she's back in
San Jose and you doing yeah I just
bought them
Popeyes my mom and dad visit in my place
so okay Popeyes and they brought kimchi
Wow I'm stopped by Popeyes huh yeah my
but their stove my phthalo you know my
friend who you know and I'll tell you
after he has a mother who is she's a
terrible person and when she's he sent
her flowers
but because he wasn't there and hadn't
been calling her as often mm-hmm he
calls her up and she goes you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ] and I'm not talking to
you and I hate my flowers and I throw
them away he hung off jonno so he goes
so he has his wife call her and well he
doesn't appreciate me he never has and
why do I care and they also sent me
these terrible flowers and he's like I
know but the flowers in her town I'll
tell you where the tenons that are there
1-800 flowers socks she goes that's his
excuse he's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
and he never comes to visit now he's so
he's his mom basically you know you
could see what I go what did you do he
goes oh I'm flying out there to see her
next weekend oh really ugly it's one of
those crazy relationships easy because I
wouldn't be Who I am without that
terrible woman like she she was such a
[ __ ] that in a way I had to
compensate this reason super successful
he's gonna go out there oh he'll go out
there with this one really oh yeah
tyrant oh well she's a tyrant um well
yeah I mean no one does anything too
crazy on Mother's Day yeah well my my
mother's so low maintenance he has a
mother where here he goes how you doing
mom terrible and every time people like
that who will just they they need you to
dote on them cuz they're I just don't
engage out of that no I just saw that
all right even if your mom I'm out yeah
I mean kiss your mom didn't you know my
mother's super-low me yeah I think it's
pretty easy she was she's 78 though and
she said I want to see you because I
went to three funerals this week and I'm
feeling very mortal it was your mom came
from Utah yeah
so say of course I'm immortal yeah
that's yeah 78 my dad is gonna be 79
that's when [ __ ] starts you know we're
sure let's do some current events man
let me pee out of my hit it hit it
what do you got Kareena Vance so there's
a new snapchat filter that's going viral
where you can see yourself as a guy or
girl and some bleach media actually did
this to a bunch of your photos leach
media isn't me if me and Brian were DRAM
Baker's we're making and deep yeah let
me go ahead how are those guys they're
so good geniuses it's got to be the same
guy right just two different accounts no
I don't think so two different guys
that's it's two different guys Jen okay
so it's so good man shoutout to both of
them hmm there it is
what is he looks like a zombie type
who's on the top right that's rad yeah
hold on that's Rogen's not bad look at
the oh I like gills I'm pretty hot he
says that potato nose Sakura
always that uh yes sir girl or something
else a girl's not good-looking
daliyah's we already ha he's alright I'm
actually hotter than doing it I wouldn't
go that far
what do you talk like a straight [ __ ]
you look terrible as a girl food
terrible you're awful
look at you you giant me I'm a I'm a
cute little D Latin yeah that's just you
with a wig on you look aged Anna called
that's just you the way got a little
chin is and oh I'm Souter looks Bell
nice um DSL yeah yeah say you little
bird for Hedda hoppers you one Chris
kinda looks like Larry David's daughter
I'm a [ __ ] guy in this thing she's
cute girl she's to date Pete Davidson
oh that's right happy Mother's Day to
these beauties and Bryan Callen is this
please me yeah yeah
[ __ ] [ __ ] god damn it cuz there's
a bigger forehead you're a D'Elia well
you know
daliyah in real life hilarious so it's
just straight filter you put on your
phone mm-hmm
so weird they would do that filter it's
funny a bunch of guys started catfishing
their friends with the photo like female
they're like what's up bro it's like my
friend thinks you're cute
mentality all right we got so there is a
youtuber who did a prank at a Walmart
that she got a lot of backlash for cuz
she pretended to be a high-ranking
member of this particular Walmart in
Texas she went up to a random woman said
that she was gonna watch over her kind
of shadow her see what she's doing and
eventually fired this woman the woman
started to break down because she just
kind of thought of her family's like
health health bills and started freaking
out
she laid the YouTuber later came out and
said that oh it's just a prank but that
woman was already basically and so she
tried to make it up to her by giving her
$50 she still posted it onto YouTube it
got a lot of backlash so she took it
down she's right here yeah this is a
clip you're fired
so I don't appreciate you walking around
here you're supposed to be at the
cashier cashing people out what if
someone was looking around they don't
see you because you're busy over here
it's an older lady that's not yeah it's
an older Filipino I don't like to watch
this bums me out and you're an ass as
one woman broke down because her
husband's medical expense depend on a
jump no youtuber socks
she's just creative she's a part of this
means YouTube crowd that does a bunch of
these like staged pranks so her entire
channel is her and her boyfriend doing
pranks each other like Oh pretending to
cheat on each other and they're
pretending they're like [ __ ] someone
else and then the other person walks in
it's basically staged pranks and they
try to do one in real life this one went
viral and it got mad she had the guy
come in and she had like shoes and she
had this guy in the bed with her and he
what the [ __ ] and he paused them he
this macho guy is Oh because what the
[ __ ] pulls it off and she's a he's a
[ __ ] you [ __ ] that's hilarious
yeah what's kind of sad is that that
bums me out don't fight a lot of
youtubers are doing this because a lot
of kids like to watch these type of
channels yeah but we're in trouble yeah
doing me in trouble and I'm like I don't
approve of me
yeah and agree it just bums me out next
one life is hard enough so that Game of
Thrones coffees chopped slip-up turn out
to be a cup of tea that Emilia Clarke
had from craft services and people
thought there was a Starbucks cup and it
actually resulted in Starbucks getting
about 2.3 dollars worth of publicity
from all of this just yes I have a dream
called the Dragon Queen tea some [ __ ]
like that yeah they should just
capitalize I'm like because they don't
own the name Dragon Queen I'm sure you
know what Starbucks is having trouble
with Starbucks is having trouble
reaching younger coffee drinkers
Millennials drink coffee like a
[ __ ]
but basically Starbucks is become
McDonald's the frappuccinos so what
happens is Millennials are like I'm not
drinking that coffee I want my coffee
over here from this like little designer
place so they're taking a major hit they
can't break in so they're hiring various
marketing firms like you know people who
do the off-white those collaborations
yeah but that's why they do like those
weird frappuccinos and like I was
talking to Starbucks and play the other
day and someone ordered like you know
the cookies and cream and she's like I
can't believe people drink that [ __ ] she
works at and she's like you we just make
milkshakes sure and she's like this is
not what I signed up for I like we just
make milkshake yeah she does you know
there's some people many people that
come here every day
order four venti Frappuccino zayday Wow
it's so many it's just all joking sure
just milk a milkshake and that's why
you're fat you know that's why you're
not that healthy I don't know man it's
it's a butt but still Starbucks is so it
says it's impossible to put a real
figure on how much advertising Starbucks
gets out of the situation but Stoli
different carrier in the product
placement kit was accidental Wow
it's be hard to identify how much money
they got but I guess they go off
eyeballs and then the the the discussion
of Starbucks but be seeing that do you
go I'm gonna go to Starbucks do they
need to get any bigger yeah
Starbucks is in still think no I
actually went to Starbucks afterwards I
don't go get coffee but I went there
because something happened I don't know
I just ended up going subliminally you
usually don't watch the show I don't but
you went there anyway cuz there was the
first time in like Wow years thing yeah
I don't know why I went there
Wow what did you get there T just a
regular hot like black coffee oh you got
coffee grande why I wanted a coffee iced
one honey what were you doing I didn't
have any instant carbon drink coffee
sometimes I drink instant at home but I
just went there because it's Ralphie do
you say you could get some great coffee
in this world and you drinking it I know
mystery more mystery the more we in
Australia together hewed eat sushi from
the gas stations I was like the
supermarket's Ralph's or whatever you
get soon we're in London's gets done in
London right and you got there's three
in the morning you get sushi from like
the checkout counter yeah in London cuz
known for fresh fish sushi
not fish and chips so she ate tuna no
tuna floating around those rivers from
the gas station something like that
that's market hazing liquor store and
though that's impressive
what else yet Jim very impressive so
this next story kind of leads into a
different one there was a woman who
broke into Chris Brown's home because
she was certain that Chris Brown put a
curse on her son Jesus Christ and when
police showed up to identify what was
happening with the alarm system they
found her her son and a bunch of voodoo
dolls everywhere but luckily Chris Brown
wasn't home he was actually at Jake
Paul's house for a party
Jake Paul is a youtuber who threw a
party for the rapper desiigner
mm-hmm and this was in the news because
a couple of women went onto Facebook and
posted that a lot of young girls from
neighboring towns close to where he
lives
we're trying to sneak into the party
they signed an NDA once they got in with
fake IDs and a lot of girls ended up in
the hospital because they were drugged
and people are just talking about this
because there's a lot of big names
attached to it there's a lot of
youtubers a lot of celebrities yeah
that's not a lot good yeah Chris Brown
was here while that woman was breaking
into his home that's his house this is
jake paul says how great how great are
their lives
you got it you got money too at 22 years
old you got that house I would do
Logan Paul's house it's a amazing crib
is it yeah when you're that to be daddy
to be my agent that money like that's
one thing to be that young what a blast
neighbor got punched know this neighbor
says that she went to call the cops
because somebody kept on knocking on her
door it was a party goer who was either
drunk or yeah high off of something she
went to go grab the phone to call the
police and she fell on the floor this is
what happened oh yeah so it wasn't
anything really oh yeah they had people
boxing in the back that's we don't know
who was boxing hey interesting that's
cool what else yet so the bubonic plague
made a surprise appearance in Mongolia
Gil has killed literally half of Europe
maybe three quarters that day and
Mongolian that that that that particular
Marmot mm-hmm is known to carry the
bubonic plague is this rodent still is
yes so they eat the kidney and get the
first you're not supposed to eat it what
were they thinking they carry that it
was a Pilate for a good health according
to new sources and a you can salt you
can cure it if you get if you get
antibiotics in time no problem is it
seems like you have the flu so you know
so you know when you're when you're in
Mongolia they go did you eat any Marmot
eat Marmot for good okay we got
antibiotics right away you don't you're
gonna die you will hold were they uh
they seemed I don't know if they put
their age but I imagine they're anyone
they were in India this couple they'd
been there for you know there they were
like it like an arm oh but they still
though couple ate the rodents were all
meat and kidney
yeah for good luck wide health good
health
which is why you might want to that's
why education ignorance kills a lot of
times and education and really
understanding science that's terrible
they had to quarantine the area for six
days Wow
thankfully no one else has it so that's
good what else you got
bubonic plague yeah oh do you want to
take a look at Brennan's commercial not
commercial but the trailer for your
special yeah
is that cool sure all right have you
seen this
how we doing my man another shop for the
road no I priced shouldn't man I'm
shooting my first comedy special tonight
oh wow good for you good for you I heard
dabbled with myself and come telling me
kisses that way three years three years
huh this one's on me
Jesus Christ this [ __ ] town thanks
man
[Music]
hey big boy tacos fellas over here they
doing I know you're big in come back oh
hey you know I'll just do three three
tacos mankind in a rush I got just food
truck chill chill big look we do DS
whoopee yo big man what do you got there
come on starving bro pretty up there
tacos
man everything come on [ __ ] enjoy man
all right thanks man ah I'm allergic to
fish
excuse me excuse me Oh easy hey doing
something yeah not much
well I'm Brendan Schaub oh my yes of
course dude come on in
Hey you're gonna love this guy
good luck our next fight God excuse me
excuse me sad damn girls yeah oh I can't
wait
BP is right big dude energy I can't wait
to get my hands on them
hi boys closer closer
Marco closer closer ladies and gentlemen
from the [ __ ]
[Applause]
hmm
how about the we have an outtake one
where chin played my boyfriend all right
yeah we did that on it thing that
commercial at for the for t-shirts yeah
are so funny
thanks man you didn't even [ __ ] move
chin Chin's my boyfriend in this awkward
we had to hold hands of so cohered
so weird all hands holding hands is a
weird thing all right next one Friday
dude Friday Friday 10:00 p.m. Pacific
ride 8 and you get free Showtime on
Showtime calm promo coach job and you
get 30 days free so Wilder fights on
Saturday night so you can get my special
on Friday for the enter of him losing to
this guy
it's boxing so you never know yeah but
yeah ok
alright you talked about the started but
do you want to go into more detail a
little bit how you're sick I just got
renewed which is awesome yeah it's all
good you know it's annoying
I like how you like like smell good oh I
like I like there's nothing worse no
it's all good it's it's great it's it's
um it's beautiful I'm so happy to be
back with the people I love and I love
the show and I love doing why did I
think it was the last you didn't they
announced his last season of gold bird
so it's because that the rumors are
doing too and they were just a bit but
wasn't that the rumor though they were
just working out the deal with that on
my thanks and so I mean I thought it was
like Game of Thrones where this was for
sure the last season well everybody's
getting older but I don't think so I
don't know I mean look I'm encouraged
that school got picked up we're good
we'll see you know I think it's a mid
season so I'm not going to the upfront
what's that mean so it'll be I think I
might be wrong but my guess is it's
going to be the same schedule it was
last year where it'll come on in the
fall which is good right yeah like what
do you care as long as that gets picked
out good yeah it's all good and when do
you when we get start shooting the new
season probably August I think
I don't need everything so soon yeah I
have to find out but I'm very grateful
obviously I'll see you know that's cool
man like I said I had to find out from
online I'm sorry
all right you know the business is
changing so rapidly you and I talked
about this like my first love has always
been stand up of course with podcast and
manure in a place now where you can just
you can make do everything make more
money and everything just doing stand-up
and podcasting and sometimes TV is not
what it used to be right it's just an
interesting thing but I have such a
blast too on the show so of course I'm
psyched about it I love everybody I
literally love everybody he does who's
involved
I can't think a one bad apple on that
whole [ __ ] production so it's gonna
be fun
congratulations thank you no that's cool
man thank you all right the next one is
this right here at a Cubs game someone
gestured what people are saying is like
white a white power symbol yeah so this
guy that did it even though they're
saying I guess his lawyers are probably
saying that he didn't do it because of
that
but he's still banned for life at
Wrigley Field well why would the guy do
that that is was very various clearly
what else is it that if he's not if it's
not that yeah and this is him doing that
guy white and they said after an
investigation they did believe that he
knew what he was doing oh yeah because
maybe in his what is a sweetie that's a
white power thing supposed to be like
the W K WNEP a third Universal sign
right wait W it was supposed to be made
up by 4chan but then it got taken on as
a real thing
from people that are white nationalists
or whatever you want to call him [ __ ]
you yeah I guess sucks what are you
doing dude your dick that guy looked
that didn't even look white I know you
like say hey if I did be like yeah yeah
like what are you doing dumbass well no
longer the words banned for life right
yeah this is interesting a New York
pizzeria a woman went there with her
daughter I believe it was and then she
left a four hundred twenty something
thousand dollar cashier's check hey wait
accidentally right and then she also
made it there she didn't tip the waiter
because I guess they have a bunch
like celebrities on the wall and she
didn't see enough women on it so I guess
her daughter or someone that when she
was with said like I can't believe that
many people women on it so that's why
they didn't [ __ ] pizza and that guy
though the waiter who actually served
them so he saw that there's no tip he
sounded so no no just practice that's
all the pictures all over the world oh
well
Patsy's but this is well know my fast
going Prince Pizza this week of course
now I'm definitely going to go to that
pizza place me too
you know and put more dudes on the wall
right there was that there was an I
wanted to bring up a current of em there
maybe we have it see Lenny was the
waiter turned out to be a pre-med
student and then he didn't ask for
anything afterwards she was cool about
it and actually gave her check back to
her PP they reached out to New York
Daily News to do this for them then they
found her and that's the one right there
hunt there oh look Tommy Tommy Lee
Davidson gave us a check that's cool oh
he's Davison Oh Tommy Lee Jones oh yes
that looks like Tommy Lee Jones
though it's identical Tommy Lee Jones
young though well there's a Florida
woman missing for six years was found in
a warehouse freezer oh you see that no
yes yeah
do you scroll and do current events they
don't want to talk about that crime
watch this be you know more about this
Lil Brennan right this is against
eliminated the Sixers yeah
Game seven here watch this game to
Hawaii Leonard
for mountain
[Applause]
oh my god
that's crazy so good I've been such a
basketball fan for so long you're just
happy that the North finally got I
looked it I looked at Brendan and I and
I saw it on jokeboys Instagram and I go
when was this oh that's so frustrating
he goes that would be yesterday right
I missed everything with the NBA and
everything oh well HHM that's pretty
much it man
Jiu Leonard dude yeah I won't be here
Wednesday man it's gonna be you and alia
probably me and crystal um I used alia
co-hosted show come see me in Orlando
this weekend Orlando this weekend then I
got Indianapolis June 6th 7th and 8th
was I forgot about and then we had Las
Vegas iron Vegas together man how the
15th I guess Rogan was at that venue
you've seen the Orleans a little tough
yeah I'm gonna be honest I'm surprised
by it myself
yeah he said it was will talk to Justin
about it yeah but where you were in
Vegas either will be their 15th come
Ryan and I the bad boys almost sold out
Orleans June 15th one night only one
show only I think one show I think right
you and me man we're we pissed in the
mouth what did you say what what
happened what are you talking about but
pissing nope I'll be in New York all
week so New Yorkers see you sir you into
each other but I'm aware I don't talk
about it I don't know we got in the show
like this dude I'll be in New York all
week Friday is the big day Friday my
special airs on Showtime again
Showtime compro McCoach shop so you can
watch it for free and you watch Walters
fight for free on Saturday and
everything else they got going on the
network Friday 10:00 p.m. Pacific that
is my one-hour comedy special you'd be
surprised drops I'll be in New York got
a week off then I'm in Cleveland I mean
Cleveland hilarities
May 30th through June first and then
just added Burbank California flappers
that is June 8th all new material so I
went to flap worth the night before my
special it's not that material it's all
new so I'll see you in Burbank I'm in
Vegas with Bryan and Calgary just wanted
sail get tickets for Brian and myself
tea fat cake
Oh put your fingers are you pistols
y'all that's a terrible way to do
congrats on your seizing in picked up
Thank You Leigh Congrats on your special
thanks to this is it good it's gonna be
a good year it's gonna be a good year
this is the father kid we're out